many of you all you're probably headed  to the grocery store to stay hydrated  pick up cases of water and all that but  you'll probably notice the average cost  of groceries  stands above just above 355 dollars a  month per person  that's according to move.org that means  two-person households can easily spend  more than a 700 bucks  a month on food and if you add a child  to that figure  well you're going and spiking that  upwards so the state with the most  highest grocery bill is hawaii new  hampshire  has the cheapest i kind of wonder where  we fall along that maybe somewhere in  the middle but i definitely have noticed  a  change of prices in the grocery store  and at the gas tank right